[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu vou apresentar para vocês hoje
a próxima grande revolução algo que vai
afetar todos os campos da atividade
humana e redefinir como nós nos
relacionamos com o mundo e com nós
mesmos mas antes disso eu gostaria de
convidá-los para uma viagem no tempo
nós vamos para paris para a cidade luz
no dia 18 de outubro de 1901
nesse dia o rei da grécia visitava a
frança ea banda do 24º regimento tocava
em sua homenagem
de repente alguém na multidão apontou
para um objeto que se levava 280 metros
acima do solo e gritou santos dumont a
multidão abandonou a apresentação os
músicos largaram os instrumentos no chão
e todos começaram a correr atrás do
brasileiro
cinco mil pessoas chegaram nos jardins
no trocadeiro no momento em que a
aeronave contornava torre enfel e
comemoraram como se estivessem vendo um
gol numa final de copa do mundo
no retorno um motor começou a falhar
santos dumont teve que abandonar o leme
e tentar arrumá lo em pleno vôo teve
sucesso mas o motor falhou ainda outras
três vezes antes que o balão número 6
retornasse com sucesso ao ponto de
partida eo brasileiro conquistasse o
prêmio do oeste
a multidão foi ao delírio gritavam se
abraçavam jogavam pétalas de flores
alguém entendeu a ele um pequeno coelho
branco outro trouxe uma fumegante xícara
de café brasileiro santos dumont
repartir um prémio de 100 mil francos
metade para seus operários a outra
metade para os pobres de paris
o napoleão dos ares conquistou a cidade
luz com seu balão número 6 e todos nós
aprendemos na escola sobre o seu famoso
14 bis o número 1
tinha uma bomba de ar fraca demais o
número 2 perdeu o leme
o número três de um formato muito
alongado o número 4 era pesado e
instável
o número 5 se arrebentou com um
castanheiro quando o motor falhou por
conta do calor
santos dumont criou o número 1 testou
número 1
aprendeu com o número um com esse
conhecimento ele criou um número 2
testou número 2 e aprendeu com o número
2 criar testar e aprender criar testar e
aprender criar testar e aprender
esse é o cerne da engenharia foi criando
testando e aprendendo que nós criamos
carros computadores conectamos o mundo
pela internet
e quanto mais vezes nós repetimos o
ciclo de criar testar e aprender mais
sofisticadas nossas máquinas se tornam
em alguns séculos deixamos de ter
carroças cruzando estradas empoeiradas
para termos espaçonaves atravessando a
imensidão do cosmos
se eu repetir se este ciclo de criar
testar e aprender ao longo de três
bilhões de anos na natureza uma forma de
vida nasce é testada no ambiente que a
seca e se tiver sucesso se reproduz
surge então uma nova forma de vida que é
mais uma vez testada naquele ambiente e
que se reproduz outra vez passando o seu
manual de construção o seu dna a sua
informação genética adiante
eventualmente surgem mudanças nesse
manual de construção uma letra diferente
uma vírgula um ponto uma palavra que é
apagada
são mutações aleatórias que fazem com
que surjam novas formas de vida
ligeiramente diferentes
essa nova forma de vida nasce é testada
e se for mais apta para sobreviver
naquele ambiente ela essas mudanças
passam a fazer parte do manual de
construção daquela espécie ou seja a
natureza cria
a testa e aprende cria testa e aprende e
depois de três bilhões de anos nós temos
máquinas extraordinárias incrivelmente
sofisticados muitas e muitas dessas nós
nem sabemos que existem outras tantas
nós conhecemos e estamos buscando
entender como funcionam mas com o
avançar da biologia molecular nas
últimas décadas nós podemos começar a
entender como algumas delas funcionam
por exemplo dentro de nós é cada um de
nós existe um exército de incontáveis
microorganismos
alguns deles muitos deles possuem um
mecanismo denominado só gelo que é
essencialmente um pequeno motor um
flagelo é duas mil e quinhentas vezes
menor do que um fio de cabelo e algumas
espécies de bactérias possuem flagelo
que operam a 100 mil rotações por minuto
uma estrutura duas mil e quinhentas
vezes menor do que um fio de cabelo que
opera seis vezes mais rápido do que um
motor de um carro do irmão nas nossas
células
existem grandes avenidas denominadas
microtubos esses micro tubos são
percorridos por proteínas denominadas se
neve nas ruas inezina é um robô
carregador que se liga a uma carga
molecular e dar pequenos passos de 8,2
nanômetros até chegar a um lugar
determinado entregar sua carga
nesse exato momento incontáveis robôs
transportadores estão percorrendo as
suas células
as plantas do nosso jardim elas possuem
um mecanismo denominado complexo antena
que é advém só uma antena que é composta
por centenas de pigmentos alinhados com
perfeição cada um capaz de absorver um
diferente comprimento de onda permitindo
que a planta cria um verdadeiro funil
energético e aumente muito a sua
capacidade de absorver energia solar
motores avenidas robôs antenas
essas são apenas algumas das máquinas
extraordinárias que os
mesmo os vivos possui e além de todas
essas máquinas e tantas outras que nós
não conhecemos eles ainda possui uma
vantagem essencial quando comparadas às
máquinas que nós conseguimos construir
os organismos são capazes de se replicar
em e de se regenerar em quem dera os
nossos celulares fossem assim o que
acontece então quando eu pego essas
peças delicadas sofisticadas que a
natureza política e à primor ou ao longo
de bilhões de anos e criou novas
máquinas com novas funções
isso é biologia sintética é criar novos
mecanismos utilizados tijolos que a
natureza forjou e aprimorou para
resolver os grandes desafios da
humanidade eu posso pegar peças de
organismos diferentes completamente
distintos e conectá-los eu posso pegar
uma peça que exerce uma função na
natureza e colocá lo em uma função
completamente diferente eu posso criar
novas peças inspiradas do que eu vejo na
natureza ou eu posso até mesmo criar
peças completamente novas
as possibilidades são tão diversas
quanto é a vida na terra ou até mais
e com tantas possibilidades eu posso
resolver os mais diversos problemas
apenas reescrevendo editando dna
alguns medicamentos são produzidos a
partir de plantas que são algumas vezes
difíceis de cultivar são de regiões
específicas do globo e se eu pudesse
então que tirar cada um dos passos
biológicos que acontece em uma planta e
colocar eles dentro de uma célula do
microorganismo como se fosse uma fábrica
microscópica eu poderia então cultivar
esse microorganismo cultivar essa
fábrica em qualquer lugar
imaginem se pudéssemos treinar
organismos para como atiradores de elite
entrar em um paciente encontrar em aceh
outro moral e destruí la
usar danos às células vizinhas imagine
se pudéssemos treinar organismos como
cães farejadores para detectar moléculas
poluentes no solo no ar na água e
destruí la
imaginem se pudéssemos e que para
organismos com armaduras para resistirem
a condições extremas utilizá-los para
colonizar planetas distantes e preparar
esses mundos inóspitos para a vida
imaginem se pudéssemos literalmente
tomar um organismo que passaria então a
habitar o nosso corpo monitorar as
nossas condições de saúde e liberar o
medicamento na quantidade e no momento
ideal como se fosse um pequeno médico
particular dentro de nós imagina criar
organismos para destruir resíduos
agrícolas industriais urbanos ea partir
disso produzir energia redefinindo o
nosso conceito de usina elétrica
imaginem vocês caminhar em uma grande
avenida noite mas ao invés de postes a
iluminar o caminho pudéssemos ter
árvores luminescentes imaginem se
pudéssemos trazer animais extintos de
volta à vida e repovoar os seus habitats
naturais
parece coisa de ficção científica de
história em quadrinho
mas a biologia sintética já deixou há
muito tempo o terreno da imaginação
todas essas tecnologias todas cada uma
delas estão sendo desenvolvidas testadas
aprimorados nesse exato momento e
laboratórios ao redor do globo
novas formas de detectar doenças de
tratá-las de produzir energia de
armazenar informação e enfrentar os
grandes desafios ambientais tudo
escrevendo e reprogramando dna
ao longo deste século a biologia
sintética criará organismos que irão
povoar o nosso solo nossa água nosso ar
até os nossos próprios corpos e isso não
é nada
nada comparado a grande revolução de
fato que a biologia sintética fará
hoje de manhã você acordou e tomou banho
escovar os dentes pegou a bike e veio
pra cá melhor de bike melhor o seu corpo
para o meio ambiente está sentado
fazendo algumas anotações mascando
chiclete
o shampoo o desodorante a pasta de dente
o pneu da bike o asfalto a tinta da
caneta até o chiclete nylon da camiseta
todos têm algum componente derivado do
petróleo
sem falar de todos os plásticos que nos
cercam a embalagem de xampu desodorante
escova de dente dessas cadeiras que
vocês estão sentados viver no século 21
é viver cercado de petróleo
eu acho que vocês já estão sabendo esse
tal de petróleo eventualmente vai acabar
e além disso alguns desses produtos não
foram exatamente que bons para o nosso
planeta
nas últimas décadas a biologia sintética
irá criar organismos capazes de produzir
cada um destes compostos a partir de
fontes como energia solar açúcar até
resíduos agrícolas
nós passaremos de uma economia baseada
em petróleo para uma economia baseada em
vida essa é a próxima grande revolução é
isso que vai afetar todas as atividades
do nosso dia-a-dia todas as profissões
todos os campos da atividade humana
todos nessa sala utilizaram algum
produto derivado da biologia sintética
se é que já não estão utilizando na
aurora do século 20
santos dumont e tantos outros violeiros
da aviação olharam para os pássaros no
céu e se inspiraram para se lançarem
seus vôos
quando deixaram o chão pela primeira vez
ainda não compreendiam não podiam
enxergar um horizonte que descortina vão
para a humanidade conectaram pessoas
encurtaram distâncias criaram uma
a comunidade global na hora do século 21
os pioneiros da biologia sintética
também buscaram inspiração na natureza
olharam sua diversidade seus mecanismos
suas formas sua beleza se lançaram então
em seus vôos pioneiros e apenas agora
começamos a antever um pouco do
horizonte de infinitas possibilidades
que existe diante de nós
nós não sabemos ainda como será o século
22 mas ele já começou a ser construído
criando testando e aprendendo muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]